bienvenue à paroles autres comme s'ils
s'y met sa mort depuis cette semaine
j'ai une question de philippe qui me
pose une question que j'aime
particulièrement c pouvez vous expliquer
la naissance du mouvement à l'homo mois
les revendications de celui ci échos là
parce que à 12 mois pour moi ça a quand
même été un moment charnière dans ma vie
non seulement à personne et d'un point
de vue personnel lorsque ça l'a
transformée dans ma vie mais ça a été
aussi un moment révélateur pour les
femmes des premières nations de
reprendre un rôle de leadership qui
était un rôle traditionnel celui qu'on
avait avant l'arrivée des premiers
européens
quand le mouvement et du moment à
commencer en 2012 c'était ça a commencé
avec un moment d'apprentissage s'appelle
un titre in qui était un atelier
d'apprentissage communautés populaires
et c'était pour parler des loi omnibus
qui allait être créée et qu'elle a envie
des protections à l'eau et là on se dit
pourquoi on enlève des protections à
l'une des plus vielles loi fédérale de
protection des rivières de protection
des deux lots qui vont être enlevées et
comme les femmes autochtones ont
maintenant un rôle traditionnel de
protéger l'eau puisque on a une rivière
milena qui coule dans nos corps depuis
nos grands mères nos mères et moi
jusqu'à ma fille ce rôle de protectrice
de l'eau c'est une responsabilité qu'on
prend très sérieusement
et quand on a compris que la raison
pourquoi enlever des protections à l'eau
c'était pour faire faciliter le passage
de pipeline à travers des territoires
des premières nations pour des pétroles
qui venait qu'elle est arrachée du sol
qui allait détruire le sol des
communautés qui allait se faire aussi au
détriment de la santé des communautés
cela crée un effet de deux minots où on
a vu dans le fond l'enchaînement des
actions du gouvernement fédéral sur les
communautés et pas seulement sur une
petite communauté dans un petit coin
mais vraiment c'était les enchaînements
tentaculaire à travers le canada qui
remontaient dans le fond jusqu'à la
à la loi sur les indiens les pensionnats
le sixties coupe les femmes assassinées
et disparues
le manque de financement d'éducation le
manque de financement des langues
le manque de protection de la sécurité
alimentaire dans les communautés
éloignées tout ça issus du colonialisme
donc la mouvance à étendre nos mois a
commencé grâce à la loi un des bus grâce
à une petite chaîne mais c'est quand
même une mobilisation qui est qui existe
depuis le début de la colonisation mais
c'est un domino qui maintenant a amené
que les rues de changement énorme par
rapport à la pratique des gouvernements
la pratique des institutions à la
pratique des médias d'ailleurs espace
autochtones et un très beau résultat
mais c'est dû à la mobilisation des
communautés autochtones
face à des lois ou à des pratiques qui
sont injustes ont à tout moment c'est se
lever peu importe où tu trouves peu
importe quelles sont tes allégeance
c'est vrai c'est de te lever contre
l'injustice contre la perte de droits
humains qu'on a perdu deux territoires
qui vont non seulement nui aux
communautés autochtones mais aussi la
population canadienne
donc merci pour la question et j'aurais
pu continuer pendant encore une heure
mais je vous invite justement posé
d'autres à nous les envoyer en espèces
autochtones et à paroles autochtone et
n'hésitez pas à partager les vidéos soit
une très belle semaine